Hello everybody, My name is Markiplier and welcome to,
"Make Me A Sandwich."
The game where, you too, can experience
All the wonders and joys
of making yourself a sandwich.
As you can see!
Before you is spread out, the buffet
of ingredients for your goddamn sandwich.
WHY THE FUCK AM I PLAYING THIS (IDK)
Okay, so..
I-I was gonna' try to, like, upsell this game,
literally, you just make a sandwich.
I don't- how the fuck do I-
I can't even move.
I don't know how to do this!
I can't grab 'em.
Why is there- Why is there no door?!?!
Why am I stuck in here?
Is this my perpetual Hell? (yes)
Just, stuck in here, making a sandwich,
everyday for the rest of eternity?
Oh- Oh- Ooh- Oh. Whoa.
I've got some vibrations in the termators! (um?)
So, when I click and hold on the termators...
Uh- OhhhhhhhHHHHhhhh.
It's a dangly doo!
OOOOOOH
It's a dangly!
Oh, so I haveta-
oooooooh
That's adorable,
but how do I bring it closer to me?
You don't-- You didn't explain
how to actually.. bring it closer.
Okaaay, so, I'm just going to operate under the assumption- this is not...
..a sausage.
This is not a sausage! D:<
This is either a turd... or a disembodied penis.
And I don't know which is worse at this time,
But I'mma put it in my sandwich any way! ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
Nothing like a dick-turd sandwich.
To lighten my day.
How about a doughnut on that thing?
WEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE!!!!!!!!!
Okay,
that didn't work.
how in the fuDGe--?
What do you- How are you-
THERE ALL IN THE DIFFERENT, DISTANCE PLANES!
How the Hell am I supposed to--
WHAT ARE YOU DOING EGG!? >:(
That's right, you better stop, BITCH
How am I supposed to be- There was no instructions in this game.
It's a bullshit stupid game!
How the fuck is it supposed to tell me what it's supposed to do!?
Good God, I'm getting infuriated.
I-I knew I was picking my battles on this one.
I was, like,
"If I play this game, it's going to be stupid, I know that."
Alright, so, put the eggie in the basket?
ooooh!
Well, that works, maybe I have to throw thi--
OOOOOOH!
This sandwich is coming together
That is not a piece of sandwich material.
EGGcUSE me? (lol)
Did that plate just float down with low gravity?
WAIT A MINUTE.
wait-
What thE  HELL?
Hang on a second here..
Somethin' ain't right about the physics in this environment.
See, I got a lot of questions.
See, I look at a game and I wonder what got me in this horrible Hell Hole that I find myself in, (because you want to)
and I've recently discovered,
that gravity don't fuckin' work! >:D
So, how in the Hell is this supposed to get together into a sandwich?
'Cause I can't even make these things to fall in the right way.
WhAt are you doing!?
That's not how you sandwich, ;)
Get... horizontal you ff
dumb
We need some tomatoes on this betch,
bam, This is a good looking sandwich right heyah.
HOOOOoooeeeeeee
That's not on the fucking sandwich, you douche. >:D
I saaaaaid..
HOOOOOOOEEEE
BOOM, okay,
Now I figured out the secret,
You gotta' angle the trajectory so it falls in a precipitous manner (Science 101 with markimoo)
TO GO ON YOUR GODDAM SANDWICH
Alright, how 'bout a dernut?
*moans*
oh, that wasn't even close
Ah- It's got the curse of the verticals.
NooOO, don't you knock any of the other ingredients off this. >:D
oh, you sack of shit
What happens if I...
Throw you down like that?
Oooo, you didn't do it!
You failed like a maroon! :(
No.. Oh. man, this is gonna' be harder than I thought.
Okay, so we got all the basic ingredients on my sandwich,
so I just gotta' cap this off and  wonder why the Hell I started this video in the-
*Inhale*
YEEEEEEAH.
Nooo...
I forgot the...
dick-turds. :(
*disgruntled growl*
How am I supposed to- Can I thread this through the doughnut?
Can I get this- ah, shit.
Fuckin' up my sammich.
Ahhh, this was suddenly very important to me.
That's not on there.
eu-geh
ahh
geh!
goo
byoo
noooOOOO
eeh
horizont-OOOOOHH
*sighs*
OH COME ON!
UUUH
fuckin
EEH
NOOOOOOO!
EEEH
There we go!
Okay, so if I could just
thread this doughnut with
this dick sausagish,
Whoosh!
Wh-WHAT?
Wait a minute!
What- I do not- NO!
NO! I WON'T HAVE A FLOATING DICK SAUSAGE!
Dick-turd sausage floating in the air is where I draw the line!
I came here to make...
a fucking sandwich...
I have to deal with this!?
W-Why? I didn't do- WHy!?
Why-Why!
Did gravity suddenly turn off?
Do these just not fall anymore?
Whats going on up there?
Whoa, I found the vortex, apparently!
What is this!?
What's going on!?
Oh- OH, now they fall.
Oh, now they fall, Oh, okay.
Well, this is my only dick-turd sausage left so I better not
do nothing wrong with it.
Oh, god- Nooo! okay.
So now, problem is, now it's not horizanal.
Come on, get horizANAl.
You're just getting closer to me, and I don't like that.
Oh- oh, god! It's gonna'- Oh, god,
The shadow of the dick, it's right in front of my face!
what. the. fuck. just happened?
I moved
I moved- No, I  moved!
My character just moved!
Oh, oh jeez
hey
hey-
How's it goin' there?
Have you seen uh,
my sausage
Oh, jeez- Oh, jesus- Oh, jeez!
I'm getting a little excited about this sandwich!
Something tells me I might have to actually blur this out,
because, that's a little too phalic like.
But anyway, lemme just finish out this sandwich.
EH no PLL BLEH-BLuh-BLEEEH
No, doughnut- Okay, that's good enough!
Okay, so I... am done making a sandwich!
IIII hope you enjoyed this video because I'm not sure if I'm going to post it
but if I do, it's going to go in the weird game category.
That's for god damn sure, so either way, that was make...
muh-make uh m-m-m meatly
*burp*
That was make me a fucking sandwich
You can play this for yourself if you want to, I-I don't know...
I don't know why you would, you got all the sandwich making capabilities out of this video right here,
It was good enough for- *muah* *muah* Very good, delicious sandwiches.
But either way,
I'll put a link in the description if you want to play it,
so, thanks for watching, really hope you.. enjoyed it.
Sorry, I wasted your time...
Have fun making sandwiches out there!
Thanks so much for watching,
And as always,
I will see you in the next video,
Buh-byeeeee!
uuugh BllLLL-EH okay, fine, I'll post it...